- So, the tour is for
your album "Gaslighter".
A lot of people relate to
this album and the message and
and just, I guess from an
artist's point of view, like,
how hard is it, asking for a friend
while I'm currently writing,
through a similar situation is
how hard is that to write so openly?
And so honest, while navigating children,
while navigating people, you know,
you're under a microscope.
Like there's so much, like,
I feel like I've written
so many songs myself,
for my personal like life,
and I keep kind of going,
ooh, should I do that?
Or, oh God. Or is that?
Did you go through that?
Like while writing this?
- I definitely wanted to be very blatant
and like literal with this one.
But yeah, I was still, I wasn't
like beyond all the emotion
like I am now.
And then there's a stress of, oh my gosh,
now my kids are gonna hear this. And then.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Now my son is on tour with us.
He's in the band and I'm
like, this is kinda weird.
(everyone laughing)
I'm always checking, are
you okay? Are you all right?
- Oh my God, I know, 'cause
that could be awkward.
- [Natalie] Yeah.
- But I love the fact
that, like, he's an artist,
so he does get the fact that like,
it's very therapeutic for us
to like, that's our outlet.
- There's no way around it.
When you write falsely, it doesn't work.
- [Kelly] It's transparent
that you're full of crap, yeah.
- You have to be, yeah,
you have to be real.
- Agreed. Sorry, I was so blunt.
- It's weird. The more specific you are,
the more it's universal to other people.
- Which isn't that so sad?
- Yeah. I know.
- I mean life is so hard. Yeah.
It's sad that people relate.
Okay, so we all went through divorces.
And how did you each find
strength? And not just music,
I think it's therapeutic, but
like your female friendships,
I feel like that has really helped me.
- Yeah. I remember when you
first came down in the studio
in Nashville and said
guys, I just wanna tell
you I'm getting a divorce.
- Which time was this?
(everyone laughing)
- Oh my gosh.
- The first one. Number one.
I remember thinking, well,
I'm getting a divorce.
Now she's said she's getting a divorce.
Now I can't say I'm getting a divorce.
It was kind, but then I was like.
- But me saying it, 'cause
you were keeping it?
- I hadn't told y'all! I was keeping,
I was feeling like
everybody was gonna judge me
'cause I was like,
I thought I was first getting the divorce.
- [Kelly] You kept that in?
- Yeah.
- So I was like, guys,
I'm getting a divorce.
And Martie's like.
- Me too!
- I'm having a horrible marriage!
- Oh my gosh!
- Well this was great 'cause I felt,
'cause I didn't know anybody close to me
that was getting a divorce.
So it was, I was so happy for you.
- I know. Wait, we were divorce buddies.